our own clumsiness can feel like one of
the most shameful things about us on
returning a carton to the fridge
we trip and spill orange juice down our
whole front it goes into our shoes too
even the inside lining of the soles are
soaked in orange pulp it's a good ten
minutes and a few towels before we've
changed out of all our clothes even our
underwear and cleaned ourselves up we
feel three and a half years old when are
we going to grow up into the adults we
supposedly are if only this were the
only such incident but clumsiness may
stalk us everywhere a month ago we badly
bruised on knee against a door then we
spilled blueberries over the kitchen
floor and recently we went around for a
whole day not noticing there was a piece
of lettuce coating one of our teeth with
furious with and ashamed of ourselves
our clumsiness violates our self-image
as competent grownups there's a Yiddish
word that artfully evokes the extent of
our stupidity the clumsy person is in
Yiddish a klutz a dunderhead a blockhead
a fool it's the inner class who makes us
drop plates who walked into doors and
who didn't remember to do up its flies
it's normal to hate our klutz and with a
grim face to try to deny it's even
really there inside us instead we strive
to hold on to our dignity and when we
can presume that the collapse has gone
away for good when we do meet with it
it's always with some horror agitation
and humiliation we thought we'd left the
klutz behind somewhere in childhood but
no it's still here getting us to drop
our phone in the toilet bowl and forget
an important person's name at a party
but there would be another less explored
option to make friends with our inner
klutz not to keep denying that it really
exists but have face up to it head-on in
good time we should accept without
rancor or fury that we simply are at one
level klutzes who knock things over
spill drinks and make fools of ourselves
in small and large ways this is only a
humiliation if we insist that the only
way to be acceptable is to exhibit
constant
once we accept that we are claps is
through and through one more spilt drink
won't need to discomfort us much further
what particularly humiliates us at
moments of clumsiness is the impression
that we're all alone with our ineptness
we wouldn't mind being clumsy if
everyone was clumsy too but they don't
seem to be we appear to have been
singled out as the greatest klutz as
we've ever met far from it
we simply don't see the clumsiness of
other people as we do our own because it
happens in private and is carefully
edited out of public life it's not
surprising that in comedy shows there is
such a widespread appetite for watching
people fall off their bikes or walk into
lampposts we feel so relieved by
evidence that clumsiness is not ours
alone it may look as if we're mocking
but really we're delighted to have found
people as absurd as we are the comedy
show invites us to see our own
clumsiness as part of a collective
foolishness not a private tragedy we can
also see that our own clumsiness is not
what sets us apart from others but
actually what we share in secret with
everyone we can accommodate our idiocy
more sweetly inside ourselves by
trusting at last that it is entirely
normal and universal to be clumsy but
it's a factor to be understood and
forgiving in ourselves because it should
be understood and forgiving in everyone
the next time we spill something down
our front we shouldn't feel a hot
prickly rage we should greet our inner
klutz like an old familiar friend with a
warm tolerant smile of recognition the
school of life isn't just a youtube
channel it's an actual school where you
can go and take classes we have branches
in ten locations around the world to
find out more click on the link on the
screen now